every story there's a character that
needs to overcome the odds that don't
know if they've got what it takes in
every story a person comes to that
character and shows them how to win
we were guiding these people real-life
stories to becoming a real-life eruption
they changed Jonathan huge cities they
sold stuff they delayed vacations all
because they believed if they did that
they could win it was never just a radio
show we were really created a movement
around the country that nobody
understood and we went hard at the
industry not only were we fighting radio
affiliates program directors we were
fighting humor financially we were
scratching and calling for every radio
station having producers say you never
make it our mission was so clear it was
changing life but nobody wanted to take
a risk on us this is what were called to
do although it get back up we're not now
no matter what the listener the number
one we are the only talk radio show
where life change even a factor actually
expecting
you just never knew how big you could
count it down
let's there a debt-free screen